i read that
um or heard that you gave away your
first gold album that you're doing like
gakers on
yeah dude did do you ever get that back
or did [ __ ] from the publicity you
got from that podcast did somebody reach
out and be like dude i have it
you know what i wish somebody would and
and i wouldn't want it back because i'd
it was meant you know it's meant to but
your first gold album dude
yeah my very i do not have my first gold
record and i know it it's scratched up
and
[ __ ] up from chopping up so much
[ __ ] gak on
and i'm i was high i was like [ __ ] bro i
want you to have it man
[Laughter]
no no it's like no dude i can't it's
your [ __ ] gold album i'm like
[ __ ] that you nap you have it bro you
know when you're [ __ ] high
sure yeah and i [ __ ] gave it away and
i don't remember
to who just was one of those where i was
like
okay maybe one day someone would be like
dude i have it
right and like but i don't want it back
but let me know if somebody's got it
that'd be rad to know
yeah dude